so I wanted to talk about how I learned
how the fundamentals of computers sort
of fit together how computers work
really um there's a sort of a mental
model that I picked up in the 80s that
has stuck with me for now 40 odd years
and even now when I sit down and try and
solve computer problems especially
performance and sort of very sort of
techy things I still kind of mentally
picture the things that I picked up from
a book in 1985 is that book was an
Usborne computer book for the Z8 and the
6502 which were the two main CPUs in the
computers of the day if you'd had a
spectrum or a BBC micro or Commodore 64
or an Apple 2 then those were the CPUs
you had they little 8bit CPUs very
simple but the really cool thing about
this is is that the stuff that you learn
to program an 8bit controller works
today when I'm sitting down with a
64-bit whizbang server in a data center
right there the same thing under the
hood nothing has changed that much since
then and so what I would like to do is
kind of explain how a computer program
works from that very basic uh point of
view each of the individual steps that
it does and U more importantly sort of
introduce you to the concepts that I
still picture when I'm thinking about
how computers work and this scales from
this really simple explanation all the
way up to the most um recent
developments in Branch prediction and
caches and out of order execution that
modern computers do so it's great but
we'll start with really simple things
the book by Osborne they've made the
PDFs available so you too can download
they sort of like totally anthropomorph
the computer and they sort of explain
the computer in terms of a set of robots
that live inside the computer and they
have things that they can do and uh
somehow the operation of these robots
caused interesting things to happen in
the outside world I will point this down
at a piece of paper give you difficulty
editing so these robots that live inside
the computer so here's my little robot I
have sort of extended what the asborn
books described for my own sort of
purposes here so for this video this
robot is a got very simple things he's
got a little Abacus and he can do very
simple sums on the Abacus and that's my
attempt at drawing an abacus and he's
got a single piece of paper which he can
write one number on so this is going to
have the number 10 on say when he's told
to do something he can use the Abacus
along with another number and he can add
or subtract from that number and then he
will update that number and there's only
literally one number that can live on
this piece of paper so if we added 10 to
this his piece of paper would now have
20 on it and so this is where he's going
to kind of store the one and only thing
he can work on at a time and we call
this the accumulator because we're
accumulating the results of what the
little robot's doing in this piece of
paper now there's not much you can do
with one piece of paper as I'm sure you
can appreciate so the robot can also go
to the ram so the robot in this instance
represents the CPU of the computer and
then the ram which is the memory of the
computer is represented in my mental
model there we are we're going to draw
it as a set of pigeon holes so it's a
huge huge array of pigeon holes and each
of these pigeon holes is labeled so
we've got 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
whatever so thousands and thousands and
thousands now I say thousands and
thousands it was thousands and thousands
in 1984 you know your spectrum had 14
8,000 of them and the BBC micro had
32,000 of them or if you were portion
had the the extended ones 128,000 of
them modern computers have billions upon
billions of them so this is the ram so
the megabytes and the gigabytes of your
memory are these little pigeon holes but
it's much easier to think about them as
pigeon holes than anything else and so
what we can put into each of these
pigeon holes is one of these pieces of
paper with a number on it so each of
these pigeon holes can have a little
piece of paper with a number written on
it and the robot can do two things with
this he can take his piece of paper to
cell and write copy the number down so
we can take number 20 and you can write
it up in here number 20 in cell zero and
pigeon hold zero or he can go to a cell
and copy down whatever numberers in
there let's say he's going to cell one
and there's a five in he can run up to
cell one take the five and copy it into
his little accumulator and then come
back to his Abacus but that's all he can
do he can't remember three numbers or
five numbers or 100 numbers every time
he has to go to a pigeon hole to do
anything somewhat meaningful now there
is one other thing that the robot has
got in repertoire he's got a little
label which I'm going to represent
actually with a label here and this is
this is like a little Index this is like
a little thumbnail or a thumbtack that
he can apply to one of these pigeon
holes to say hey um this is where I am
if I'm in the middle of doing a whole
bunch of operations then this is the
point where I'm going to come back to
before so just with some very very
simple operations and I'm going to write
down the list of operations let me put
that somewhere where we can still see it
the robot can he can go to a pigeon hole
I'm going to call that loading so that's
loading a number from a pigeon hole into
the accumulator so he can load a
number and he can load from a pigeon
hole and when I load it from a pigeon
hole I'm going to put a little at sign
to say this is the uh pigeon hole number
that I'm going to load from he can also
just write down a particular number if
you want to put like the number seven
not the contents of pigeon hole 7even
but just the actual number seven we can
just load seven and I'm going to use a
little hash there to mean this is the
number seven as opposed to the address
of seven and this would be like load at
10 to say load at the address 10 he can
also load up wherever the index pointer
is pointing at so I'm just going to say
a special thing that says load at index
and that says wherever that little pink
index marker is go and read the number
that's inside that pigeon hole that
particular pigeon hole all right and
then similarly we want to be able to
write back to this pigeon hole we need
to make changes to it so we can say
store and we can either store at a
particular address so store at like
pigeon hole 7 or we can store at where
the index is we can also add subtract
multiply for the purposes of this little
demonstration I'm just going to write
down one of the things that we're going
to do and I'm going to say we can add
and again you could like add a
particular number so like add seven and
that means add the number seven to
whatever's on your piece of paper and
replace it with that we could also add
with the contents of one of those pigeon
holes so this would mean let's do 13
this would mean go to pigeon hole 13
note down the number temporarily and
then add it to the Abacus and write that
number down so if you've got 10 in the
accumulator and you go to sell 13 and
that had number seven in it you'd add
the 10 and the seven and your new
accumulated value would be 17 and then
we've got a couple of other operations
that we need in order to do something
slightly interesting so we can increment
the index that means move it along to
the next box in the array of boxes we
can also decrement the index which
obviously means to move it the other way
and and then finally we can jump or go
to an earlier place in our program
because what we're going to do with
these uh instructions that we have
available to us is we're going to build
a little program and that's like a
recipe and we want to be able to go back
to an earlier step to to do this a
sequence of steps over and over again so
this would be jumped to some spot okay
so what can we do with this simple steps
that the robot can do we would like to
put them together so I'm going to use
this to write out a program
to Output the Fibonacci sequence of
numbers which is if you remember one and
one and then you add the two previous
numbers to those numbers to get the next
one so 1 + 1 is two 1 + 2 is 3 2 + 3 is
5 3 + 5 is 8 and then I'm not going to
test my own mental arithmetic at under
under the gun to check that but I think
it's 13 and as I was explaining that to
you that's kind of the way that the
computer would do it too right I said I
wrote down one and one I know the first
two Fibonacci numbers are one and one
and then for every subsequent number I
said go back and add the previous two
numbers together and then write that
next one out now we've got nowhere to
write in the robots running around the
computer world but what I can do is I
can put them in subsequent pigeon holes
in my memory so that's what we're going
to do so how might we start this out um
well the first thing I want to do is I
want to put the two ones in the first
two Loc in the pigeon holes and so how
am I going to do that I'm going to say
step one load the number one into the
accumulator and so our robot in fact I
can write here's my little accumulator
I've got a little piece of paper here so
I might as well pretend to be the
robot um I'm going to write the number
one here that's step one
fantastic uh the next thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to store so step two
store that at address zero I'm going to
say the zeroth pigeon hole computer
people love to start at zero as I'm sure
you're very well aware it's never caused
any problems at all um starting at zero
instead of one we're going to store that
in the zeroth location and then we're
also going to store it in the oneth
location it is all zeros and ones um I'm
going to get one more piece of paper
we'll come back to that one of course
I'm going to have to raid the place
where paper lives in any household which
is the printer drawer so I'm going to
make a new empty memory array of pigeon
holes and so after having done these
first three operations I would have put
one in my accumulator oops I'm holding
this the wrong way around and I would
have put it in cells zero and one so one
would go in here and one would go in
here fantastic okay so far so we've done
the first two numbers of the Fibonacci
sequence nobody is that excited right
now what we would like to do is start
keeping track of this uh of a process we
can repeat over and over and over again
as to make the next uh number what I'd
like to do is use the index register
this little purple pink thing to take a
note of where we are in the sequence I'm
going to start by saying let's put it at
the beginning of the boxes so the fourth
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
say load the index oops I realized I
didn't write down that that's something
the Lo the robot can do but we're going
to say put the index at cell zero okay
now we're into a bit that we are going
to do over and over and over again step
five we're going to load the number
that's at the index which obviously we
know what it is at this point because
we've just put one in there but to have
a sort of General thing we can do over
and over again we we're we're going to
do the same step over and over again so
we load out the index that's going to
read the number one into our accumulator
Well turns out it was already there
we're going to
increment you load blitzes out whatever
else was there doesn't it into the
accumulated that's right so we would
have thrown away the one and then we
would have load back in a new new one a
fresh shiny one from our collection I
know yeah oh I love the smell of a fresh
one um and then we're going to increment
the index and incrementing the index
moves it along to the next cell then
we're going to say well add to the
accumulator using our
Abacus add whatever is at the new place
where the index is well again in this
instance we're going to go to the we'll
run off to the the cell it's a one in
there and we're going to replace this
one with the sum of those two which is
two
hooray okay we're getting
somewhere uh step
eight we're going to increment the index
one more time because now we want to put
this result this new Fibonacci number
we're going to put it in the next cell
so we're going to move the index over to
index 2 which is currently
empty and then step nine we're going to
store at wherever the index is pointing
so now we'll put the number two over
here in our pigeon hole and I think we
can see where this is going now what we
need to do is we need to set it up ready
for the next step right we need to um
set ourselves up so that we're ready to
go round the the loop again to do this
over and over again and so what we need
to do is put the index at the beginning
of the pair of two numbers that we want
to add together and in order to do that
we need to move it back one so in Step
10 we're going to decrement the
index so now he's pointing at one and
then finally we're exactly ready to do
the next Fibonacci number so in in Step
11 we're going to say go to or jump what
did I say I said jump didn't I jump to
step uh five
step five so I'm going to put a little
draw line under here and you can sort of
see where we are so then if we were to
carry on which I'll do very quickly we
would uh load at the index we put one in
our accumulator move the index along one
we get two add whatever's the the index
now to this to get our
three move the index forward again to uh
get ourselves into an empty cell write
the number three in
here and move the the index back and off
we go forever and so now we have an
infinite sequence of Fibonacci numbers
uh and a program that never ends which
is a whole other problem but that's cool
right we've just used very very simple
very very simple uh instructions that
the robot can do um and we've been able
to build a Fibonacci program so that's
cool and all but there's one other kind
of really nice thing that you can sort
of get from this understanding of how a
computer might work first of all you
know putting numbers in boxes first well
it sounds very abstract which it is
numbers in boxes are not that exciting
so two things one there can be another
piece of circuitry or another sort of
robot if you like that that makes some
of these pigeon holes connected to in in
modern day the brightness of LEDs or LCD
pixels on a screen and so you could
imagine if we had some set of pigeon
holes like from say pigeon hole a
million to a pigeon hole 1,500,000 each
of those corresponds to a pixel on a on
a monitor
and now suddenly by writing numbers to
boxes we're making pictures happen
somewhere so that's one sort of
observation and back in the day
certainly on the BBC micro um there were
ways of getting the TV screen to display
so that you could write say the number
65 which just happens to correspond to a
capital A in ASI and a capital A would
appear somewhere on the screen on the
BBC micro now when you're 10 years old
that's an earth shattering moment when
you realize that literally changing
numbers inside the memory of your
computer to make something cool and
interesting happen on your screen so
that's awesome and we can definitely dig
into that some other time but what I
would like to do is sort of show you how
this little program that we wrote which
you know we've written on paper how I
might be able to teach the computer this
program because at the moment I've just
said there is a program maybe this is
all the robot can do which is a very
boring robot and certainly doesn't play
Elite or Exile or any of the cool games
that I used to play so let's go back to
my list of all of the instructions
noting now that that we're missing one
which was the load the
index so here is the list of all the
things the robot can do and I'm going to
number these instructions I'm going to
say this is instruction zero this is
instruction one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10
so we've got 11 because again we started
at zero uh 11 different things that the
robot can do and so I could actually
encode the whole program as a sequence
of
numbers so let's try doing
that here is my my program just make
sure I can see them so I'm going to sort
of draw a new area of screen I couldn't
find green fan field field feed paper
for the life of me during lockdown I was
posting it to people but it I bear it's
it's there are people who will sell it
on Etsy for any amount of money uh it's
ridiculous but anyway with so our
program I'm going to make it into a
sequence of numbers so load number one
is the first step of our program so this
is a load of an actual number load hash
which is in our case is instruction
number one so the first number in our
sequence that is going to represent our
entire program is one and then we
actually need the number one so I'm
going to say one is the next number and
the the robot will know having read a
one that let load whatever the next
number is into the accumulator so one
means load and then the one is the one
that it's going to load into the
accumulator I'm going to write these on
different uh lines just to kind of keep
some track of it and obviously you can
see how this is going once I start doing
it the next instruction is store at zero
now store at is instruction number three
so we're going to say three
Z and then we want to store at one which
is going to be three 1 and so on you
could imagine taking each of these high
level high level operations that the
robot can do and encoding it as a
sequence of numbers now this this is the
machine code that the computer the CPU
deep down even today actually executes
it's all it can do so you've seen any
number of like programs like python or C
or uh you know you're using Excel or
whatever to write programs in ultimately
the only thing the computer can do the
only thing the CPU at the bottom of it
can do is understand a sequence of
numbers just as I've described here
obviously a little bit more complicated
than just the 10 instructions I've got
but actually not as not that much more
complicated because once you've got a
few of these things you can build any
program you like where are we going to
put this machine code right this is this
is fantastic this is a way of explaining
the to the computer what I want it to do
but can I feed it into the side of the
computer I don't know what to do well if
only we had a massive array of empty
boxes that I could put a sequence of
numbers into so that's exactly what
we're going to do what we would do is we
would take our let's find a our original
thing here we just go and find a spare
set of boxes let's say this is box 1000
and I would write the sequence of
numbers in that we've got from
assembling as this is called the
assembly code this is the human readable
form of what we're asking the computer
to do into the machine understandable
form of just a sequence of numbers so in
box a th we'd have 1, one we'd have 1 3
0 3 1 etc etc etc and then when we get
to the jump if you remember we said jump
the end of this program would be go to
step five well step five doesn't make
any sense to a computer now but what we
can do is we can say which pigeon hole
for it to go back to so by by the time
we get to this this would be about you
know I'm I'm not going to bother
assembling the whole thing here
otherwise we' be here forever uh 10,2
let's say is the jump jump is
instruction number n and then in the
next box we'd have to put what number
box we need to go to and let's say it
was you know 106 something like this so
this would jump to 106 and we're going
to ignore the fact that in these types
of computers you can't put the number
10,6 in a pigeon ho um that's for
another day but this was a watershed
moment for me as a kid as I realized
that everything could be expressed very
simply and from those very simple things
you can build anything and of course as
a kid or you're interested in is
building video games and moreover just
the right sequence of numbers is
actually how the computer works and um
once you kind of got your head around
that you kind of understand a lot of
things like for example if we were to
actually run our Fibonacci program now
after the thousandth Fibonacci number it
would start overwriting box 1,000 which
is unfortunately the program we're
actually running and I think we could
see what would happen with that
eventually the robot would write over
its own program and something UNT would
happen we haven't said what would happen
if the robot read you know number 11 or
14 you know in modern processes that
would be a crash and you would see
something horrific happen and hopefully
your operating system would say you know
oh there's been a fault of sorts this
the screen would certainly Go a
different color on my computer yes
that's right yeah yeah so definitely
whenever things have crashed and you see
all this kind of nonsense um stuff
appearing all over the top of the screen
that's because the the the processor the
robot's going AR and has written over
the pigeon holes that actually
correspond to the picture you're looking
at which is
amazing because we can shoot Rays out
and we can do thing what's important
here is that when you shoot the Rays out
here executor from this and then we will
see that we are generating a thousand
around numbers here we were very lucky
there's no failure